an informed conservative says something
like well yeah there's a problem there
but let's not get ahead of ourselves and
presume that we actually know how to fix
it in a way that won't just make it
worse right right you know and for me
like I'm kind of temper mentally
predisposed to be more on the liberal
left end of things from a personality
perspective because I'm high in a trait
called openness which is a good
predictor of say liberalism and and more
left-wing thinking although I am also
high in conscientiousness which is a
good predictor of more right-wing
thinking but what really convinced me to
become more of a traditionalist I would
say was this realization of unintended
consequences is that it's very very
difficult to make alterations to a
complex system in a manner that doesn't
make the system function worse instead
of better and so I think generally
speaking that especially when you're
perturbing extraordinarily complex
social systems that you should be firmly
aware of the limits of your intelligence
and the probability of you're biased
interpretations of course and I love
that you brought up this term
traditionalism I actually made the case
a couple days ago that I think Donald
Trump himself may be counter-intuitively
exhibits many aspects of traditional ism
in the Edmund Burke Michael Oakshott
sort of sense of things and I wonder if
now as you've noted and channeling
Nietzsche that you know at a certain
point in our culture God died for our
cultural purposes and ideology replaced
it where are we now are we in a post
ideological age is God striking back
against well the thing is one of the
things that's really not necessary to
note about Nietzsche is that when he
made the pronouncement that God was dead
it was by no means triumphant of course
yeah so some people misunderstand that a
lot oh definitely the full phrase is is
I'm paraphrasing but the full phrase is
something like God is dead we have
killed him and we'll never find enough
water to wash away the blood right right
right and and and that was associated
with thoughts he had at the same time
that the consequence of the death of
this traditional value structure on the
idea of a transcendent moral structure
and
an ultimate moral responsibility would
be replaced by two things one would be a
kind of hopeless nihilism and the other
would be a swing especially into leftist
totalitarianism which he directly
predicted as did Dostoyevsky although
that wasn't the only logical
totalitarian outcomes of course so I
mean he had that nailed it's a it's
actually one of the most amazing
prescient predictions that I've ever
encountered indeed in any way do you
find a link between that nihilism that
came came out of the death of God and
left-wing totalitarianism and these
campus snowflakes and the Peter Pan
syndrome and The Pajama Boys this
apathetic malaise whiny bratty culture
that we're seeing among perfectly
luxurious young healthy wealthy
generation well you need a you need a
direction right and and without that
you're bereft certainly a positive
emotion but you're also hyper anxious
you know that that's the thing that's
kind of odd about having direction and
responsibility is that it gives meaning
to your life because it it helps you
understand how the small things you do
everyday are related to crucial and
important goals without that it's very
very difficult to orient yourself in the
world